>> Dana: THE WAR ON COPS IS
GETTING WORSE, UNFORTUNATELY,
LAST YEAR SAW A DISTURBING
INCREASE IN POLICE GETTING
KILLED ON THE LINE OF DUTY, 331
OFFICERS WERE SHOT, 64 OF THEM
LOSING THEIR LIVES AS ROUGHLY A
21% INCREASE OVER THE AVERAGE
FROM 2010-2020.
THE POLICE UNION HAS A THEORY ON
WHAT'S.
>> WE HAVE A CULTURE OF
LAWLESSNESS THAT HAS GRIPPED
THIS COUNTRY.
IT'S BEEN FUELED BY AN OPEN
BORDER, ACTIVIST JUDGES, A
REVOLVING DOOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM, AND GENERALLY A SOCIETY
THAT TELLS PEOPLE YOU ARE NO
LONGER ACCOUNTABLE FOR YOUR OWN
ACTIONS.
>> Dana: PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS
AN IDEA ON HOW TO HELP THE
POLICE.
>> WE HAVE TO RETRAIN COPS AS TO
WHY SHOULD THEY ALWAYS SHOOT FOR
DEADLY FORCE?
THE FACT IS, IF YOU NEED TO USE
YOUR WEAPON, YOU DON'T HAVE TO
DO THAT.
AND LOOK AT, TO CALL A FRESH
APPROACH TO RECRUIT AND HOW WE
RECRUIT, HOW WE HIRE, HOW WE
TRAIN, HOW WE PROMOTE, AND HOW
WE RETAIN, RETAIN
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
>> Dana: AND WHILE POLICE
OFFICERS ARE DEMORALIZED AND
DEPARTMENTS DEAL WITH
RECRUITMENT STRUGGLES, THIS IS
NOT HELPING COME OF THE L.A.P.D.
BANNING A THIN BLUE LINE FLAG
FROM ONE OF ITS STATIONS
FOLLOWING A COMPLAINT FROM
SOMEONE WHO FOUGHT AND
REPRESENTS RACIST BIGOTED VIEWS.
ANY THOUGHTS ON WHAT JOE BIDEN
SAID TODAY ABOUT HIS THEORY OF
JUST SHOOT THEM THE LEG?
>> Greg: I DON'T THINK HE
KNOWS WHAT HE IS SAYING,
REMEMBER, I DON'T KNOW, IT'S
SAD, BECAUSE WE ARE STILL
RECUPERATING FROM A SPASM OF
ANTI-COP HATRED FOR FOUR YEARS
AGO, THREE YEARS AGO, WE ARE
STILL NOT BACK TO NORMAL, THERE
HAS BEEN A DELAY, A LAG BETWEEN
WHAT WE KNEW WAS WRONG AND WHAT
PEOPLE ARE DOING ABOUT IT, I
MEAN, WE STILL HAVE TO HAVE A
DEBATE OVER NO CASH BAIL, RIGHT?
HE STILL IS BAD MOUTHING COPS,
JUST LIKE HE BADMOUTH THE
IMMIGRATION, THE BOARD OF
REGENTS, MEDIA PROVED ELEVATED
ANTI-POLICE SENTIMENT TO SUCH A
DEGREE THAT FIGHTING CRIME HAS
BEEN PERCEIVED AS RACIST, THAT
EVEN BY SUPPORTING THE POLICE
THAT IS SOMEHOW RACIST, I DON'T
KNOW IF WE ARE EVER GOING TO GET
BACK TO NORMAL AFTER THIS, I
THINK THAT'S WHAT WE WILL
PROBABLY SEE IS AN EVOLUTION
TOWARDS PRIVATE POLICE FOR THOSE
THAT CAN AFFORD IT, AND EVERYONE
ELSE GETS A GUIDED BEAR POLICE
FORCE IN THE INNER-CITY, IT WILL
BE LIKE FIRST CLASS COACH, IT
WILL BE LIKE RESERVE SEATS IN
GENERAL ADMISSION, OR PRIVATE
AND WORSE, IT WILL BE LIKE
PRIVATE AND PUBLIC BATHROOMS,
BECAUSE OF FACT AS THE PEOPLE
THAT ARE PUSHING A LOT OF THE
STUFF TO OUR WEALTHY DEMOCRATS,
THEY DON'T HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT
THEIR SAFETY, THEY DON'T --
THEIR POLICIES AND THEIR
PERSONAL CONSEQUENCES NEVER
MEET, SO I HAVE A FEELING THAT
THIS IS GOING IN A WEIRD
DIRECTION WHERE WE WILL HAVE
JUST TWO SEPARATE POLICE FORCES.
>> Dana: THOROUGH TRAJECTORY
OF ALL OF THIS IS NOT GOOD,
JUDGE, AND IT CONTINUES, BUT HOW
DO YOU THINK THAT COPS ACROSS
THE COUNTRY WILL REACT TO WHAT
PRESIDENT BIDEN SAID?
>> Judge Jeanine: IT FURTHER
ADDS TO THE MORALE PROBLEM, THE
FACT THAT THEY HAVE BEEN
DENIGRATED, DEFUNDED, YOU KNOW,
DEMORALIZED, I MEAN, THE COPS
NOW KNOW THAT STATISTIC, THE BIG
STATISTIC THIS YEAR IS IN 2022
SAW A DISTURBING INCREASE OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT FATALITIES,
65-2022, WHICH IS SOMETHING LIKE
21% OVER THE AVERAGE OF 53 OVER
THE LAST DECADE, SO THEY KNOW
THAT THEY ARE BEING SHOT AT AND
KILLED, THEY ARE BEING AMBUSHED,
THEY ARE BEING BADMOUTH, AND
THIS SAYS NOTHING.
AND THAT'S WHY THEY ARE LEAVING
THE FOREST, MANY OF THEM BEFORE
THEY ARE EVEN ELIGIBLE FOR
RETIREMENT, BUT I WANT TO TALK
ABOUT THIS L.A.P.D. CHIEF
MICHAEL MOORE, CHIEF MORE, YOU
ARE A WILLIS.
YOU ARE A WES, I GOT THE WORD
RIGHT THIS TIME, I WOULD'VE GONE
TOUGHER, BUT I CAN'T.
THE TRUTH IS, YOU REPRESENT THE
PEOPLE IN LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
YOU AGREED BECAUSE ONE PERSON
COMPLAINED THAT YOU ARE GOING TO
TAKE THE SIDE OF THESE COP
HATING PEOPLE WHO HATE
LAW ENFORCEMENT, YOU ARE GOING
TO BUCKLE TO THE LEFTIST
APOLOGISTS, AND THOSE PEOPLE WHO
HATE LAW AND ORDER, SHAME ON
YOU, YOU OUGHT TO GET THE HELL
OUT OF THERE, I KNOW YOU WANT TO
BE A CHIEF OF POLICE, BUT YOU
WORK FOR COMMUNIST, MAYOR BASS
IS BEING TIED TO AND SUPPORTING
TOP MEMBERS OF THE
COMMUNIST PARTY OF THE
UNITED STATES.
THEY DON'T CARE ABOUT LAW AND
ORDER, THEY ONLY CARE ABOUT
ANARCHY AND HE IS JUST
SUPPORTING IT, THAT'S WHY THE
UNION IS WILD OVER THIS.
>> Dana: JOEY COMING TO TALK
TO SOMEBODY AT THE L.A.P.D.
TODAY?
>> Joey: WE SURRENDER THAT
WHICH IS SACRED, ONLY COWARDS DO
THAT, AND IF THIS THIN BLUE LINE
SYMBOL IS SACRED TO THOSE THAT
LOSE BROTHERS AND SISTERS ON THE
POLICE FORCE, WE ARE NOT BEING A
LEADER BECAUSE HE BELIEVED THAT
SOME BUT HE HAS CO-OPTED COMING
FIGHT BACK AND TAKE CONTROL AND
USE IT APPROPRIATELY AND YOU OUT
TALK THE BAD TALKERS.
YOU ARE LOUDER THAN THEY ARE
WITH THE SYMBOL THAT A SECRET TO
YOU.
I WANT TO KNOW WHO COMPLAINS
ABOUT THIS?
IT'S NOT A SINGLE MOM WHO WAS
WORKING THREE JOBS AND COMES
INTO THE POLICE FORCE OR COMES
INTO THE PRECINCT TO ARGUE
AGAINST A PARKING TICKET SHE CAN
AFFORD, THE DAD WHO GETS HIS
ROWDY SON OUT OF JAIL AND ABIDES
BY THE LAW NO MATTER WHAT COLOR
OF SKIN THEY ARE, THE PEOPLE
THAT COMPLAIN ABOUT THIS
ACCORDING TO THE PEOPLE THAT
WORK THERE ARE SKILLED
ANTI-POLICE ACTIVISTS WHO
UNDERSTAND THE COMPLAINT SYSTEM
AND KNEW EXACTLY WHAT TO DO TO
INCLUDE FILING THIS COMPLAINT
FROM MY UNDERSTANDING FOR MY
FRIEND THAT WORKS AT L.A.P.D.,
FILING THIS COMPLAINT AT THE
SAME PRECINCT TO THAT OFFICER
ARROYO WORKED OUT OF ON THE
ONE-YEAR ANNIVERSARY OF HIM
BEING MURDERED BY A GANG, THEY
ARE SENDING A MESSAGE AND THIS
POLICE CHIEF IS JUST ACCEPTING
IT.
>> Geraldo: I AGREE ABOUT THE
GEORGE FLOYD HANGOVER, I THINK
THAT SOCIETY IS STILL SUFFERING
FROM WHAT HAPPENED IN
MINNEAPOLIS.
AND WHAT HAPPENED AS A RESULT OF
IT IN THE EXTREMES THAT IT WENT
TO AND THE DAMAGE THAT WAS DONE
IN THE SCHISM THAT WAS CREATED,
AND IT IS VERY SAD TO ME TO
FOLLOW UP ON WHAT JOEY WAS
SAYING, THAT THIS WONDERFUL
SYMBOL OF THE THIN BLUE LINE HAS
BEEN CO-OPTED BY SOME PEOPLE
THAT ARE RACIST AND BIGOTED.
BUT THE ONLY WAY YOU FIGHT THAT
IS TO TAKE IT BACK, FIGHT IT
BACK, GRAB IT BACK.
FLY IT ON YOUR FRONT LAWN, WHERE
THE PIN, CELEBRATES THEIR
RELATIONSHIP WITH COPS, THEY ARE
THE THIN BLUE LINE BETWEEN
ANARCHY AND CIVILIZATION, THAT
SOUNDS OLD-FASHIONED SOMETIMES,
BUT IT IS STILL TRUE, WHAT WOULD
THE WORLD TO BE, WHAT WOULD
AMERICA BE, WHAT WITH THIS CITY
OR YOUR CITY OR YOUR TOWN BE
WITHOUT A COP, A COP THAT YOU
COULD TRUST AND CALL ON COMING
YOUR KID IS CHOKING OR SOMEONE
HAS BEEN SHOT OR THE STORE HAS
BEEN STUCK UP, OR THIS, OR THAT,
WHO DO YOU CALL?
YOU CALL THE COP, YOU CALLED A
COP, SAY YOUR PRAYERS AND HE
CALLED A COP, I THINK THAT IT IS
REALLY -- IT IS INFURIATING, AND
JUST SAY IT SO SIMPLE, THANK YOU